Hey youtubers It’s charlie, since arrow
and the flash just released this, here it
is, picture teasing their big crossover.
I wanted to dedicate a video to explaining
how it’s going to work as well as give a
big update on every single comic book show
DC has in development right now.
Including the ones that they just announced
but haven’t made it to air yet.
Like Supergirl.
Hello any new people, If you just found me
I’m doing arrow and flash videos all season,
be sure to subscribe to join the team.
Also big heads up, they delayed the arrow
season 2 netflix release because of the dvd.
The people that make arrow, like stephen amell,
mark guggenheim the show runner.
They have absolutely no say in things like
that.
I don’t want to speak for them, but if there
was a way for them to get episodes to you
faster, they would totally do it.
With that in mind if enough of you want it
I will dedicate a bonus video to a big season
2 recap.
Only if you think it’s needed.
So just let me know about that in the comments.
Now for some sweet crossover music.
This picture is from the table readthrough,
meaning they all sit around giant tables reading
their lines in the script.
Just to explain who’s in this picture and
what’s going on.
First off, if you look closely, you can see
Stephen Amell is wearing his Arrow costume
leather pants.
They just call them the Arrow pants, which
I think is funny.
Then from left to right there’s Glen Winter
the director of the two episodes, it’s a
two parter.
Danielle Panabaker who plays Caitlin Snow.
She may or may not secretly have powers, David
Ramsay, Jesse Martin who’s playing Detective
West, Candice Patton who is Iris West, and
has her arm wrapped around Emily Bett,
Rick Cosnett who plays Eddie Thawn, keep your
eyes peeled on him, Stephen Amell in his tight
pants, Grant Gustin, Patrick Sabongui who’s
playing the Captain of the Central City police
department where Barry works,
Marc Guggenheim who’s the showrunner on
Arrow and Tom Cavanagh, who’s playing Harrison
Wells, the person who runs Star Labs.
The crossover is a little bit different than
what you’re used to.
Because both shows are owned by the CW which
is owned by Warner Brothers, which itself
owns DC Comics and the rights to all DC Universe
characters.
The Arrow and Flash people have a few liberties
that other shows don’t.
And on top of that, The Flash show was grown
out of Arrow, both in terms of characters
and in terms of production staff.
The people that are writing and running The
Flash originally wrote and produced on Arrow.
So they’ll all a big family.
Which is very rare in Television.
Structurally the crossover will be a two hour
story broken into two 1 hour parts.
Each of those one hour parts will take place
on each show.
They haven’t formally announced which show
the first part will happen on, but The Flash
airs first during the week.
So if they want to complete the crossover
in a single week, they’ll do part 1 on The
Flash and part two on Arrow the next day.
That’s what I’m hoping happens, just because
who likes waiting a week to see part 2 of
anything?
We don’t know what the story device will
be that will merit Team Arrow being on The
Flash show and Team Flash being on the Arrow
Show.
It’s possible they could pick an event out
of the comics to use or it could be some original
event.
The Flash as a show is sticking very close
to the Flash Rebirth storyline, but Arrow
plays a little more fast and loose with the
comics.
What you can plan on is one or two characters
from each show going on the other show.
They won’t have every single member of team
arrow and team flash on screen at the same
time.
Logistically it would be a nightmare.
Since last year’s mid-season finale turned
Barry Allen into the Flash, I would bet on
something major happening.
Like the reveal of the Reverse Flash or Zoom,
or however they’ll defining the big bad
on that show.
I’ll talk more about that character in a
separate Flash video.
But of all the big reveals they could make
there’s The Reverse Flash, Brandon Routh’s
Ray Palmer could join Team Arrow full on,
he could also get his supersuit, the Rogues
could come together as a team for the first
time and we could see Ra’s Al Ghul for the
first time.
Any one of those things could happen or a
couple of them at the same time.
They didn’t cast Ra’s Al Ghul till after
they shot the first episode, so he’s not
going to be in the premiere.
Which reminds me, they just cast Captain Boomerang
on Arrow.
He’ll probably get tied up in a Suicide
Squad storyline.
But the actor the cast, Nick Tarabay, was
also on Spartacus with Manu Bennett.
I like the meta thing going on.
Captain Boomerang has both been a member of
The Rogues in the Flash comics and The Suicide
Squad.
So it’s possible his character could be
involved in the crossover episode.
Some other big happenings: Brandon Routh,
like I said could possibly get his Atom Suit
during the midseason finale.
He just did an interview where he explained
they’d just finished shooting 6 episodes
and he’d seen concept art of it.
I’d plan on it looking closer to something
like this but without the super bright colors.
Just toned down a little.
The midseason finale will be episode 9 of
each show, so his interview was from a couple
weeks ago.
It does take them a while to make those special
suits like Roy’s and Oliver’s, so we might
not see The Atom’s till right before the
last episode next year.
In terms of character arcs, Brandon Routh
said most of his scenes in those first six
episodes are just with Felicity.
Meaning, we’ll see a lot of Felicity and
Ray Palmer doing things without Oliver around.
I feel like people will love Ray Palmer, but
hate Ray Palmer and Felicity.
Maybe not everyone, but he’s going to be
a romantic foil for oliver.
Brandon Routh said it’s his job to come
between Felicity and Oliver, so he’s looking
forward to the fan response whether you love
the new ‘ship or totally hate on it.
Oliver is the real protagonist of the series,
so ultimately we root for him.
So when someone comes between him and Felicity,
of course we’re supposed to not like it.
Speaking of Felicity though, Mark Guggenheim
has been teasing some Felicity Related Behind
the scenes stuff.
First he posted this picture.
It’s the inside of Felicity’s Apartment.
Tumblr went nuts with this.
Just look at the poster above her TV.
Robin Hood, totally appropriate.
Then just as I was making this video, like
literally in the last hour.
He also posted this image.
It’s a sign from Sherwood Florist.
In the Longbow Hunters story in the comics,
when Oliver Queen and Black Canary moved from
Star City to Seattle, Black Canary got a flower
shop and named it Sherwood Florist.
The two of them lived in an apartment above
the shop.
The building the shop was in served as their
base of operations, so Arrow could turn Sherwood
Florist into the new Verdant for the arrow
cave or it could just be where felicity’s
apartment is located.
In the trailer we saw her working a nerd herd
looking job, so I don’t think she owns the
flower shop like in the comics.
Just as a big reminder.
Arrow and Flash Premiere in 3 weeks.
The Flash is on Tuesday nights and Arrow on
Wednesday’s.
Both at 8PM Eastern Time.
I know a lot of you in international countries
aren’t sure when you’ll get new episodes.
But just check the channel listings for wherever
they normally broadcast Arrow episodes.
Now, here’s the details for all the new
Comic Book Shows DC has in development, these
are the ones that aren’t on air yet:
First up there’s a new super dark animated
version of Justice League from Bruce Timm.
If you’re not familiar with him, he’s
basically the guy behind all the best DC Comics
animated shows like Batman the Animated Series,
Batman Mask of the Phantasm, Batman Beyond
and the Justice League cartoon from about
10 years ago.
When they say darker version, think of it
being more like Batman the Animated Series
in terms of tone.
No word on when we’ll get to see this.
It takes up to 6 months to animate a single
episode, so it might be 2016 before we see
anything.
Then there’s the live action Teen Titans,
they’re just calling it Titans.
I already did a video about this so I’ll
add a link in the description.
That’s still in the pilot stage.
Next there’s Supergirl from Greg Berlanti
and a co-writer.
Berlanti is also the guy behind Arrow and
the Flash and a whole bunch of other new non-comic
book shows.
They are still getting ready to shop it to
networks.
It won’t be on the CW and the show won’t
be called Supergirl.
If things do work out I would plan on seeing
this in fall 2016 maybe 2017.
Next is Hourman, Geoff Johns announced last
year the CW was developing an Hourman show
based on the dc comics character.
It’s been 10 months with no news, so this
project could be dead.
And if the CW isn’t going to do wonder woman.
It’s possible the Hourman project could
move to a different network.
Fox Networks, the same people making Gotham
just bought the rights to Lucifer.
They’ll be turning that into a live action
show.
The character Lucifer Morningstar originated
in Neil Gaiman’s Sandman comics and eventually
got his own spin off comic.
Fox just bought the rights, so we probably
won’t see this till 2017.
Next is Preacher, it’s based on the comic
by Garth Ennis.
Seth Rogen and Adam Goldberg.
These two guys are developing this for AMC.
A showrunner and executive producers have
been hired.
So this seems like it’s moving along nicely.
But I wouldn’t plan on seeing any news about
it till next year.
With maybe a 2016 premiere date.
Scapled, the Vertigo comic is in development
at the WGN network, it’s being described
as the Sopranos on a native american reservation.
There isn’t a showrunner yet, so they’re
probably still working on pilot scripts.
DMZ, another vertigo comic, is in development
at SyFY.
It takes place in a post-civil war New York
City, Which has been turned into a Demilitarized
Zone, thus the DMZ title.
Syfy is also turning Frank Miller’s Ronin
comic into a miniseries.
It’s about a Ronin Samurai who failed to
protect his master from a demon.
He wakes up 800 years later in modern day
in the body of a new person and has to fight
the same demon for control of a magical sword.
As of right now that’s it.
Usually this is the time of the year when
networks buy new shows, so if any new comic
book shows get announced it probably won’t
be till next year.
Here’s the big question though.
Of all the new shows I just listed.
Which are you most excited to see?
Right now I’m really looking forward to
that new Animated Justice League.
My next video will be for constantine, I’ll
be doing a breakdown of the character and
the series for people who have never read
the comic.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I have seen the first episode, so I’ll post
a review next week.
It’s not premiering till the end of october
so it’s still a long ways off.
Right now click here to get that explainer
video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here for my non-spoilery Gotham
Review.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!